what is going on everybody welcome to
part 29 of our matplotlib tutorial
series here we're gonna kind of ran
start rounding out this series with
3-dimensional plotting with matplotlib
so let's go ahead and just hop right in
so 3d plotting with matplotlib is
actually already included with
matplotlib we don't have to add any
extension like basemap so all we need to
do is from MPL underscore toolkits dot m
plot 3d import axes 3d then as we always
need import matplotlib pie plot as p LT
so now we're ready to rumble first we'll
add the figure will say fig equals P Ltd
figure and then we'll add an axis we'll
say a x1 equals fig dot add underscore
subplot we'll just make it a 1 by 1 by 1
and then or one by one chart number one
and then we add this other keyword here
and this is projection equals and 3ds so
this is our way of notifying Python that
hey we're about to throw three
dimensions at you if you forget that
it's just not gonna work but with that
it's pretty much all you need now what
we're gonna do is we need some X's and
Y's and some Z's so we're gonna say x
equals a list y equals a list and Z
equals a list and now let's give some
numbers here so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 and 10
now you can copy it if you want but I'm
just putting random numbers in here so
just put some random numbers try not to
make them giant like that and just so we
have enough numbers and then we'll do
okay so that's a good decent we've got
some X's and Y's and some Z's so now
what we can do is we can just do a x1
dot plot underscore wireframe and then
we'll plot the x the y and z in our
wireframe now we can give labels like
we've always given them so X 1 dot set
underscore X label
we'll give this the label of x-axes ax1
dot set underscore why label y-axis and
then finally X want to set underscore Z
label z axis whoops
z axis can't type anyway now finally we
round it all out with the traditional
PLT show and save and run there we go
quite an interesting little graph that
is come upon us anyway there it is so
it's a three dimensional graph you
should be able to click and drag
probably looks a little better on your
screen when you click and drag the mind
I believe I record in like five frames a
second or something so it probably looks
pretty jittery but should be pretty
smooth for you until you add a lot of
points the other thing to note is the
axes labels they're like no matter like
where you put it it's like always nice
so if you'll notice that x-axis flips a
little bit once it starts getting a
little absurd also the side of the axes
will flip around too so it's it's really
nice and intuitive kind of nature that
this three-dimensional plotting gives
you but regardless it's a 3d plot labels
still work and all that you can't really
zoom what you can do is you can hold
your right right Mouse and like zoom in
and out like that and that's kind of an
interesting thing you can do as far as
zooming is concerned you can really get
absurd with it if you wanted but anyway
so you can do that but for the most part
everything else kind of stays the same
you can't really use the other buttons
like you would you used to be able to
anyway that's just a really quick
example of a 3d plot obviously this is a
pretty boring wireframe at the end we'll
do a more interesting wireframe the next
tutorial what we're going to do is we're
going to cover three dimensional scatter
plots so that's what you have to look
forward to if you have any questions
comments something go wrong or whatever
up to this point let me know otherwise
as always thanks for watching things for
all the support and subscriptions until
next time